[Musique]
le chaos total autrefois après de
grosses tempêtes de neige
10 pouces de neige en buteur paralysé
autrefois nos villes pendant plusieurs
jours pour régler le problème Arthur
Sicard montréalais invente la première
souffleuse à neige en 1925 pour se faire
il s'inspire de la moissonneuse batteuse
qui sert à récolter le blé dans les
champs il pulvérisait la neige pour
l'envoyer
75 pieds plus loin et c'était son son
mécanisme pour propulser la neige qui a
été le local de son invention et de son
innovation le problème de l'enlèvement
de la neige est à peu près résolu depuis
que l'inventeur canadien français a
construit une machine reconnue comme la
plus efficace c'est la plus rapide au
monde une souffleuse remplie en effet en
moins de 15 secondes un camion de 5
tonnes
c'est la Ville d'Outremont en 1927 qui
achète la première souffleuse à neige
Sicard
c'est ensuite le gouvernement du Québec
et la Ville de Montréal qui se procure
cette équipement et l'invention
québécoise est exportée par la suite et
bien partout dans le monde et faire
en Russie
c'était invention a aussi joué un rôle
très important dans l'entretien et la
sécurisation des pistes d'atterrissage
que ce soit maintenant ou il y a 60 ou
75 ans et bien le déneigement a toujours
été une source de frustration pour les
automobilistes
[Musique]
mais c'est indéniable la souffleuse à
neige d'Arthur Sicard on ne peut plus
s'en passer le fait qu'on ait oublié
comme ça Arthur Sicard qu'on ait oublié
son nom ou qu'on ne relit plus le nom de
Sicard avec cette invention de la
souffleuse à neige et ben ça nous
rappelle qu'il faut faire un effort
collectivement pour nous souvenir de nos
grands inventeurs de nos pionniers la
compagnie Sicard et maintenant disparue
mais l'invention est là pour mon temps
ici jacques Bissonnet Radio-Canada
Montréal
[Musique]